[Music]
in the previous video we studied what
motion is we also saw one type of motion
called a rectilinear motion it's nothing
but straight-line motion in this type of
motion the part of a moving object is a
straight line but what if the path of a
moving object is circular yes you
guessed it correctly if an object is
moving in circles it's undergoing
circular motion more accurately it's
defined as the motion of an object along
the circumference of a circle the
circumference of a circle is the length
of this boundary which is curved so if
an object is moving along the
circumference of a circle we say it's
undergoing circular motion can you give
me any real-life examples in which
objects execute this type of motion what
about the satellites orbiting the Earth
yes a satellite orbiting at a certain
height it's also undergoing circular
motion what are there examples of
circular motion can you think of take a
small object and type to one end of a
rope take the other end of the rope in
your hand and whirl it around in circles
you see that the object is performing
circular motion notice that the distance
of the stone from your hand is always
the same what about the moving fan is it
also undergoing circular motion first
let's only consider the motion of a
point on one of its blades if we switch
on the fan we will see the point moving
in circles so we can say that the blades
of the fan are also undergoing circular
motion now what if I take the fan as a
one single object can I say that the fan
as a whole is moving in circles no that
would be incorrect
the fan as a whole is not going anywhere
the entire fan is not moving along the
circumference of a circle but which
motion is it performing then the fan is
undergoing rotational motion before
actually defining this type of
Oshin let's try to understand it first
this rod here is called the axle and the
entire fan is spinning around this axle
or you can also say that the entire fan
is spinning around this fixed line this
type of motion is what we call
rotational motion now we will define it
in simple words a body is said to be
performing rotational motion if it's
spinning around some fixed line and the
fixed line is also called axis of
rotation what are the examples of
rotational motion can you think of what
about a rotating wheel we use the word
rotating because it's performing
rotational motion
what does axis of rotation in this case
yes it lies on the axle of the wheel so
the wheel is also undergoing rotational
motion about this fixed line other
examples of this type of motion can be
the earth spinning around its axis and a
spinning top but wait a moment let's go
back to our example we discussed earlier
when this object was whirled around in
circles we said that it was performing
circular motion but here if we take this
line as our axis of rotation then we can
also say that the object is performing
rotational motion around this fixed line
so what is the motion of this object
circular or rotational what exactly is
the difference between the rotational
and the circular motion in all the
examples of rotational motion that we
saw the axis of rotation is a part of
the object it is going through the
object but in this case the axis of
rotation is not passing through the
object
it's totally separate from the object
hence we don't call this motion as
rotational motion does this circular
motion and not rotational so this is the
difference between circular and
rotational motion if a body moves along
the circumference of a circle we say
that it's performing circular motion and
if the body is spinning around the fixed
line called the axis of rotation and if
that axis of rotation passes through the
body we say that it's undergoing
rotational motion in the next video we
will see one more type of motion see you
there
[Music]
you